now to new details on the toxic train
derailment in eastern Ohio where fear
and outrage is growing CBS News has
learned employees at the Norfolk
Southern say they had expressed concerns
about the train that crashed suggesting
it could be too long and heavy anger
boiled over at a town hall meeting last
night as locals complained of health
concerns since the accident Roxanna
Siberian is in New Waterford Ohio
Roxanna good morning
good morning Nate authorities lifted
evacuation orders in East Palestine last
Wednesday just five days after the
accident since then many people in this
area have told me they've started
coughing and getting rashes that fish
are dying and pets are getting sick it's
clear they want answers
[Applause]
outrage poured over at a town hall in
East Palestine last night as anxious
residents grilled state and local
officials
yeah
not present rail operator Norfolk
Southern
[Applause]
CBS News has learned that some of the
company's employees had previously
expressed concern over the excessive
size and weight of the 151 car train
which was 9 300 feet long and weighed 18
000 tons they say it had suffered at
least one breakdown on its route before
it derailed in East Palestine
despite the numerous toxic chemicals
released Ohio Governor Mike dewine now
says tests on five steel encased Town
Wells show it's safe to drink their
water and health officials say the air
quality is back to pre-accident levels
but resident Melissa Blake says two days
after the derailment doctors diagnosed
her with acute bronchitis from chemical
fumes they quarantined me they gave me a
breathing treatment they had to put me
on oxygen they were going to wash my
clothes because they didn't know what
was on me one of the chemicals on the
train Vinyl chloride is classified as a
carcinogen and there were other
chemicals as well we don't know what is
a safe concentration in the air in the
soil and the water of any of these
compounds CBS News medical contributor
and oncologist Dr David agus says the
long-term health effects of industrial
chemicals on people are not well studied
and so when this happened there wasn't a
Playbook of we can do X and Y if this
spills they're developing The Playbook
as we speak what's your biggest worry
that is never going to go away
it's going to get worse
in response to claims that the train was
too long and heavy Norfolk Southern
tells CBS News the weight was quote
uniform throughout with features to
reduce mechanical issues It also says a
longer and heavier train used to run the
route Gail boy Roxanna that's very scary
that woman you talked to was just saying
out loud what a lot of people are afraid
of and thinking thank you